.
- Pas une de plus!
- (foule): Pas une): Pas une de!
- C'est un message clair que ces
femmes o
la violence faite aux femmes
doit cesser.
- Je suis chez nous, puis
qu'il y a des féminicides
ailleurs. Même ici, au Québec,
il y en a.
ça a beaucoup aussi de... derép.
On les oublie des fois, mais
puis ils vivent ça aussi
avec les femmes.
- Même après six ans que
je me su
toujours des mesures de sécurité
parce qu'on ne sait jamais..
- L'actualité des derniers jours
l'a une fois de plus démontré.
de Laval aurait tué ses deux
enfants enfants enfants et auraé
sa femme. Puis, deux jours
plus tard, une femté tuée par st
à Vaudreuil-Dorion.
CHRISTINE GIROUX, survivante
de violence conjugalel y al y aa
quelque chose comme ça,
ça touche tout le monde,
mais moi, ça me touche
- C'est que Christine Giroux
connaîn
les conséquences de la violence
conjugale. Elle a quitté
fois qu'il sort de prison,
il la retrouve.
- La violence conjugale,
ça va loc'est extrême!
MANON MONASTESSE, dir. fédér
maisons hébergement pour femmes
- C'est quand même une femme
qui est tuée par son conjoint
ou son ex-conjoint
- Manon Monastesse constate
l'escalade de violence depuis
ement pour femmes
de la province sont rempliesà px
nombreux féminicides s'ajoutent
les tentatives de meurtre.
qui nous ont dit qu'elles
avaient été victimes
d'une tentative de meurtre
et que ça n'avait pas été
rapporté création
du Tribunal spécialisé en
de violence sexuelle
et conjugale et la mise sur pied
des bracelets antirapprochement.
impératif de pousser
la conceus loin.
IAN LAFRENIÈRE,
député CAQ, Vachon
premièrement. On ne travaille
pas un contre l'auontre l'auont,
on travaille ensemble. Il faut
que les hommes fassent partie
c'était le message que j'avais
r aujourd'hui,
mais on est très conscients
que c'est pas terminé.
à toutes celles qui se sontétei.
- Christine Giroux,
qui a organisé cetuer
de marteler son message.
- Je trouve qu'on en parle
seulement quand c'est médiatisé.
Après, on n'en p dans l'ou dans.
- Jusqu'ici en 2022, 12 femmes
sont mortes aux mains d'un
conjoint ou d'un ex-conjoint
violent;n de trop.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Mon